the collector of souls surrounded by
screams the guardian of Hell precisely
it seems consumes the bad devoured by
wrath strong vile powers don't enter his
path lives for the pain embraces his
crown watch out for the king that lay
underground shortly after the Olympians
defeated their father Cronus the reign
of the Titans came to an end
assuring in the new rule of the
Olympians Hades and his brothers Zeus
and Poseidon decided that they would
divide the rule of their new kingdom
amongst each other with the Zeus rule in
the sky Poseidon the ocean and Hades
having rule of the underworld
it is the rule of the underworld Hades
that we'll be focusing on today we know
that the Titan Cronus was Hades his
father and his mother was a Titan
Estrella Hades was the oldest of the
three male Olympians and he was the
fourth born of the original six
Olympians the domain that belongs to
Hades is now what we've come to refer to
as the underworld but it was also
commonly referred to as Hades in the
name of its ruler
the underworld is believed to be hidden
deep beneath the earth and was
considered to be surrounded by five
rivers Acheron the river of woe Cocytus
the river of lamentation the Phlegethon
river of fire sticks the river of
unbreakable oath and Lessie the river of
forgetfulness
past the five rivers is a diamond gate
guarded by the three-headed hound
Cerberus deep within the underworld
there is a vast Palace that belongs to
Hades his palace was said to have rooms
made entirely of silver and gold
decorated of all sorts of precious
metals and jewels since Hades had access
to all the riches under the earth these
chambers were described by Persephone as
a dazzling wealth of brilliance to even
rival that of Mount Olympus
one can only reach the palace if hades
wishes them to those who are not welcome
can walk an eternity without ever
reaching it upon death one soul would be
led by Hermes to the entrance of the
underworld
once there there was a ferry that would
carry them across the river Acheron
there was only one ferry run by the
boatman known as Charon he only took
those across who could pay the fare in
order to prepare for the payment coins
would be placed in the lips of the Dead
when they were buried those who could
not afford the fare were trapped between
the underworld and the realm of the
living once the ride had come to an end
the souls were allowed to pass through
the gates by Cerberus who would only
ever allow souls to enter never to leave
they would then appear before the three
judges Rhadamanthus Minos and Akos who
would decide the severity of their
sentence based on their actions in their
previous life those considered to have
lived a good honest life would be sent
to Elysium field the others were
sentenced to be tormented for eternity
it was known that Hades preferred to
spend his time in the underworld and
though he was traditionally depicted as
one of the twelve Olympians he only ever
ventured to Mount Olympus to commune of
the gods in matters of great concern
despite the underworld being he's
Dominion Hades was not considered to be
the god of death that was an honor that
belong to an entirely different god
named Thanatos much like his other two
brothers Hades was a greedy god and took
a keen interest in growing his kingdom
he took pride in the subjects he
collected taken a liking to those whose
actions caused death which could be why
the originals were treated as honored
guests within his kingdom the people of
ancient Greece feared Hades so much that
they believed even saying his name would
result in death coming quicker this led
to Hades being referred to by the Greeks
as pluton or Pluto by the Romans
Hades then became the god of wealth
because of the precious metals that will
be mined from deep within the earth this
also included the wealth of fertile soil
that would nourish the seeds in grain
Hades was often depicted as a dark
bearded Stern and stoic unyielding ruler
who adamantly defended the deads right
to burial he was often seen on his ebony
throne wearing a helmet given to him by
the Cyclops during the War of the Titans
granting the wearer invisibility
you
the weapon that is most commonly
associated with Hades was his by dn't a
two-prong staff that resembles a
pitchfork capable of shattering anything
in his path and not to be confused with
the three-pronged Trident of Poseidon
although not directly a weapon of Hades
Cerberus is a frequent companion and
often referred to as the Hound of Hades
despite his immense power Hades was
regarded as the least powerful of the
three brothers with Poseidon being the
second most powerful and of course Zeus
the most powerful now we mentioned
Persephone at the start of the video she
was the daughter of Zeus and Demeter and
she would eventually become wife to
Hades but in order to make her his wife
Hades had to manipulate and trick her
but that's a story we'll be covering in
a later video
with Hades being such a predominant
figure in Greek mythology he features in
hundreds of stories most of these
stories would involve individuals
attempting to enter the underworld one
of the most well known was in the 12
labors of Heracles Heracles was given
the task by King Eurystheus of venturing
into the underworld and bring him back
with him Cerberus in order to prove his
fearlessness and strength upon arriving
in the underworld
Heracles asked Hades for his permission
to take back Cerberus Hades was
impressed by the respect and courage
shown by Heracles to ask him such a
thing the only condition Hades said was
that Cerberus was not to be harmed
this meant that Heracles would have to
wrestle the beasts of his bare hands
Heracles did eventually managed to bring
back Cerberus to show King Eurystheus he
was even able to return the Hound to the
underworld unharmed another similar tale
is that of Orpheus who traveled to the
underworld in search of his wife
Eurydice Wolfie s was a renowned
musician and upon arriving he's musical
skills impressed Hades so much that he
allowed him to leave with his wife on
the condition that until they reach the
surface he was not allowed to look back
at his wife
Orpheus agreed but as a test Hades had
given him the wrong soul Orpheus so
eager to glance at his wife once again
looked back breaking his promise and
losing his wife for a second time
[Music]
these stories quite clearly indicate
that Hades was not an evil God when
individuals came to him in their time of
need he chose not to turn them away but
instead he gave them the chance to earn
what they desire it seems that he is not
against helping those in need but only
if they can prove themselves worthy
[Music]
the most recent depictions of Hades in
movies and games often show him as being
evil the villain of the story and
sometimes he appears more like a demon
than a man I guess we can attribute this
to Hades been a dark and morbid
character whether you like Hades or not
there is no denying that he is one of
the most interesting gods in Greek
mythology
what about you guys is Hades a God that
you're fond of is he a God that you
haven't heard much about or is he a God
that you do not like I personally feel
that Hades is one of the misunderstood
gods there isn't much to suggest that
Hades was evil but thanks a lot of
movies and games he now has his
reputation of a villain in comparison to
some of the other things done by other
gods
Hades does seem to be one of the most
fair and just gods in Greek mythology if
you've enjoyed this video then please
consider leaving a thumbs up as it helps
promote the video and allows the channel
to grow if there's anything you'd like
to discuss or have any ideas for future
videos then please let me know in the
comment section as always I've been your
host mythology and fiction explained
[Music]